[music]
>> Hi, I'm Luis Romero Sevilla and I'm the
VP of AI at the Orbifold operation.
I'm on a mission to solve knowledge
representation when all context matters.
So, let's start with a very specific
example.
Let's say we have a large number of
documents and all documents represent an
event and all documents in the
collection are relevant to answer a set
of questions that the user has.
Not only that, there's one more
challenge.
The document in the collection becomes
obsolete very fast and all documents get
replaced with new information.
Let's start with a simple approach. We
could start with a simple rag. For that,
we just need a vector database and an
embedding model.
An embedding model takes the documents
and turns them into a learned numerical
representation, a vector.
Now, we take those vectors and we store
them in a database optimized for
performing operations with the vectors.
Perfect. Now, we can take all of our
questions,
>> [music]
>> turn them into vectors and then look for
a vectors that are similar to the
initial query.
Those vectors that are within the trip
similarity threshold are retrieved and
we can pass them to the LLM to answer
the question.
Inserting to a vector database, it's
relatively fast. So, whenever a
collection becomes obsolete, we can just
replace it with a new one.
We still have one problem with our very
specific scenario.
All the documents in the collection are
relevant for us to answer the question.
So,
we can't just take all the documents in
the collection and pass them to LLM.
That's just one of the many limitations
with this approach.
Wow.
>> [screaming]
>> Now, let's get a bit more sophisticated.
All documents are relevant to answer a
global question.
Therefore, there must be some
connections and relationships between
the details within a document in the
collections. For us to map out those
relationships,
we're going to need a knowledge graph.
And one implementation we could try is
GraphRAG.
GraphRAG has many steps, but basically,
>> [music]
>> it uses an LLM
to read through all the documents and
extract key entities and relationships
between them.
It constructs a network, a knowledge
graph, where all those connections and
details are tied together. Then, when a
question is asked, it navigates this
graph to synthesize a complete answer
drawn across the entire collection. If
your collection of documents
isn't changed very often, GraphRAG is an
excellent approach for finding those
relationships within details to answer
the user's question.
However, our very specific scenario
states that our data is not only deeply
interconnected,
but also the data gets replaced very
often.
Recomputing a knowledge graph every time
the data gets replaced is
computationally very expensive, and it
takes relatively long time.
Okay, what if we take an even simpler
approach and we continue to build on top
of it? If we were to use something like
GraphRAG, each document needs to pass
through an LLM [clears throat] for the
entity and relationship structure
anyway.
Why can't we just throw all the
documents into context?
This approach would look something like
"cache augmented generation" (CAG),
where we use a model with a large
context window, load the documents into
the context, and cache the context by
storing the model's KB matrix.
The problem here is that the context
window is limited, and if you fill the
context window too much,
the quality of the answer gets degraded,
too.
The solution: what if we use more CAGs
in parallel and distribute the documents
across different context buckets.
Now, each cache can answer questions
regarding its content.
And now we just need
something to ask the right questions to
the right buckets.
So, for this, we can use a smarter model
to interrogate each bucket and
eventually synthesize an answer.
How do we distribute the documents?
It sounds tempting to organize the
documents by domains and tell the
supervisor, "Hey, here are the different
categories." But in practice, with very
dense relationship between documents,
the supervisor tends to ignore domains
that at first glance
seem irrelevant.
For this reason, all documents are
distributed in no particular order. The
only requirement is to balance the
number of documents in a way that the
least amount of documents are needed.
Then the supervisor model start
exploring the buckets and progressively
builds its internal understanding.
And if it finds something interesting,
it can ask a specific bucket follow-up
questions.
Because all caches can be loaded in
parallel,
the knowledge building process is
significantly faster
than graph rag while providing more
accurate answers than a simple rag.
And you're probably thinking, "KV cache
can be pretty expensive." And you're
absolutely right.
But there are ways to reduce that cost
by optimizing how long each cache lives.
And at the end, there are many retrieval
strategies,
and all of them have their trade-offs,
whether it's compute, cost, speed.
Currently, there is no
one-solution-fits-all.
So, each type fits our solution to our
very specific problem.
Thank you for watching. And for any
questions or continuing this
conversation, going to leave my details
here.
>> Mhm.